quels débouchés les hommes sachez le ce
et 38% sont là à rechercher une femme
cultivée 42% sont d'abord à rechercher
une femme qui fait très bien l'amour est
ensuite viennent la beauté 12% et la
richesse lui pour cent c'est quoi vous
alors présents parfois c'est l'humour le
mot d'humour les mains les mains très
important mais oui mais il n'y a pas la
main avaient alors là seulement voilà
non non non je dirais cultiver ses
l'abstrait bien d'amour est très belle
donc le tibet en multi le mytho vous
allez vous dire mathieu mathieu to my
home made me lasser l'époque par faut
parfois ça c'est vrai je vous le jure
c'est le producteur qui envoie un texto
je peux vous le montrez ouais mais c'est
vrai ah ouais donc on les garde pas
parce qu'on se permet de communiquer
avec l'arrivée chrtr c'est lui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors les voici rigide de la vérité non
au régime du mordant temps soit pas la
fumée non non excusez moi non arrêtons
maintenant monsieur de leurs mots j'ai
danger ici une oreillette reliées à la
production qui dirige déjà envoyé au cas
texto tu sors voilà en effet je n'avais
pas de cette oreille alors que tu crois
à un tarif pas faire des missions sans
oreillettes et le chef quand il n'est
pas là c'est moi alors ta gueule
photo ça n'est pas mon cas moi je peux
faire le lancement après la pub tu t'es
coach ta mère tu vois la confiance chez
ma mère et le petit fils de micro ni
kevin 2001 faut mais je sais pas je ne
vaux je vais je vais réfléchir hockey
quoi pour l'instant je suis pas pour
piloter s'il a hérité nom me pousse
dehors à auxerre valenciennes est ce que
vous voulez chez vous voilà c'est le
gameplay c'est mon rêve aux eaux
c'est vrai ça c'est vraiment est ce que
vous voulez chez vous que memphis donc
reprennent après la pub mais vous plaît
non mais je l'avais noté
mais sans un paquet télécoms sa je me
casse la figure et que je me pète le
quelque chose je sais pas s'il va
marquer mais j'ai pas trop parler de
benjamin ce soir ouais c'est vrai je me
sentais l'épargné en fait et ça dommage
parce que j'aime beaucoup mais c'est un
mec cool et à qui on peut parler de tout
en toute décontraction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est benjamin lui l'a fait une partie
de poker ce week end
ouais tiens le roi du poker d'ailleurs
on sera poker un jeu avec plaisir ça
fait dix ans que j'ai pas joué mais bon
si vous voulez s'était évadé depuis dix
ans alors et il a gagné
non je fais kit turbo core qui fait
quitte à me dire qu'il a perdu aux jets
mais finalement j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
faits qui t'a fait deux fois que vous me
dites que vous avez utilisé fecit daffé
qui tu kiffes équipe type
donc ça veut dire vous n'avez rien gagné
on est un père doit l'accepter pas
effective d'accord c'est un petit peu
l'histoire de votre vie mais c'est vrai
il n'a rien gagné n'a rien perdu samareh
tu reviens bien bassam à redire sur les
amours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'hôtel est tranquille
tornade du métier on est à l'aise je
viendrai d'origine
il a joué au poker ce week end oui est
ce qu'il a fait que j'ai gagné à la max
à montbéliard
merci
de ses toiles en baissant est présenté
dans les années son boss et je joue à
part jamais bon allez on a les benjamins
[Applaudissements]
toujours ce qu'on a toujours le revoir
au téléphone lowrie est sympa
redoutez-vous s'était levé certaines
chansons pas très bien où habitez-vous
il va se marrer aussi vous mettez vous
dans leurs athlètes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux pas répondre à la demande
visible
bien sûr est-ce que tu m'entends